rural broadband provision sorry start
again straight on providing rural
broadband presents many challenges and
I'm talking now to Martin Anza who is
coming up with one of those obstacles in
Switzerland right now Martin you are
looking at providing a network in a very
rural part of Switzerland tell us about
about the region and the challenges our
project is in uber lawless overall this
is part of valley one of the contours in
Switzerland it's a German speaking part
of that country it's in the Alps ranging
from 500 metres above sea level up to
four thousand six hundred metres above
sea level and it's a quite a challenge
to build an FTTH network there because
as you see the density of inhabitants is
not as big there we speak about 30
people 30 inhabitants per square
kilometer only and this is calculated
with the small towns we have already yes
so that's a I guess that's a financial
consideration in terms of only having 30
people you know within a small area but
what about as well some of the some of
the actual physical difficulties in
installation I mean does that present a
problem as well with all the valleys you
talked about yes you can imagine our
district our region has a big main
valley there it's probably bit easier to
build a fiber network and then we have
the side wellies with a lot of rocks a
lot of mountains and I can give you an
example we have one village we founded
490 people and their to build the feeder
was quite interesting we had to use the
utility power duct going from 2,200
metres down to the valley of five
hundred and eighty meters so it's five
kilometer duct that we needed just to
build a feeder up to this village and
while it's costly and challenging also
like that yes because I think you you
harnessed utilities and also the
national provider Swisscom to help you
to enable this network is that is that
right that's exactly the the
coordination or corporate
model that we have it's really important
to have strong partners first partner
Swisscom they are also investment and
building partner so they pay sixty
percent and they build fifty percent of
the network in their ducts and the other
part the donít part our part is also
fifty percent we pay forty percent in
the ducts of the local utilities so
these synergies that we have there with
the ducts existing ducts it's really
crucial for our project that's very
interesting and what are some of the
benefits now that the people are going
to be able to say from their new network
as you can imagine far away from the
cities today you don't have the best
network even on copper so for some
villages it's really from let's say back
in the one mega society up to the 100
mega society it's a huge jump first is
and the second is to be connected with
the rest of Switzerland let's say you
live in the Alps and you can work there
like homework staying connected to the
world I think this is a really crucial
for our future to be connected and quite
apart from the sheer business benefit
it's a nice feeling to have done
something to improve people's lives
isn't it yes that's a big fact and we
have also some feedbacks in in this this
topic already so there are people saying
if I have an ftth network in this
village mountain up two thousand
thousand five hundred metres above sea
level I could imagine living there so
working probably two or three days in
Zurich lang yeah the other days I'm back
in my mileage yeah important also for
the demographic very interesting yeah
Martin good luck with the rest of the
project thanks very much for talking to
us thank you very much frying so rural
broadband in Switzerland a real teamwork
to achieve
you